AI teddy bears could be reading
customized bedtime stories to your kids
within five years this is according to
VTech Holdings Hong kong-based twine
electronics company they're looking very
closely at the use of AI within toys and
they would equip the toys with a chat
GPT style intelligence they're hoping to
do it by 2028 and so what they'll say is
you can incorporate not only the kid's
name but the kids daily activities but
which school who your friends are it can
actually be telling a story and talking
almost like a good friend the kids can
actually talk to the toy and the toy can
actually give them a response I think
this is a a very bad idea this
technology is designed to alleviate
loneliness I am lonely but all of the
evidence that we have is that the result
is really the opposite